uh we have yet another example now of
failed former president donald trump
being given the opportunity to just
cleanly condemn the russian president
vladimir putin and his invasion of
ukraine and he doesn't do it last night
the former failed president was
interviewed by fox news propagandist
sean hannity and in a moment we're going
to get to some of this uh windmill stuff
trump's still very confused about
windmills and we're going to do a little
bit of a deeper dive into
windmills and birds
but before we get to that here's the
opportunity hannity just says it is this
evil just tease up an easy one for trump
to condemn putin
and trump doesn't delivering another one
of these word salads take a listen to
this asked you the last time you were on
whether you think that this is evil in
our time do you believe this is evil in
our time right i think in 100 years
people are going to look back
and they're going to say how did we
stand back and nato
stand backwards so that's a criticism
of nato and of biden understand hannity
says it is this evil is putin evil is
what russia's doing evil and he goes
the history books are not going to look
kindly at nato and the united states and
biden now also remember well let's play
a little more in many ways i've called a
paper tiger don't forget
i rebuilt nato because when i became
president the first thing i noticed when
i went there to the first meeting was
that
most of the countries were not paying or
were paying far less than they were
supposed to there were only eight out of
28 countries that were paid in full the
united states was not only one of them
we were making up the deficits in order
to protect europe we were paying
possibly 80 percent of nato to protect
them and then they take advantage of us
yet on trade because on trade they're
every bit as bad as china they treated
us very badly on trade we changed a lot
of that around but they were very tough
on trade i asked angela merkel how many
chevrolets guys remember the question
was is it evil what putin is doing and
trump's criticizing nato
implicitly criticizing biden for not
doing enough and now criticizing angela
merkel are you selling this month in
munich
or berlin
and she looked at me well probably none
i said you're exactly right none and yet
we had the mercedes benz and the
volkswagens and all of them we had all
of the german companies and the same
thing with farmers our farmers sell
virtually nothing
to europe you take a look at
how crazy is that i mean really how
bonkers is that it is is is putin's uh
invasion evil
why aren't americans uh american cars
being sold in germany that's really bad
and nato's bad and biden's bad and and
by the way we've trump seems obsessed
with why you don't see people driving
around in chevies in germany guys i i i
hate to be critical of american industry
but like if you can get a volkswagen
locally produced if you can get a
mercedes or an audi locally produced
why are you gonna say get me an american
chevy i mean they're
germany has very good cars like it's
it's anyway so another opportunity to
just plainly cleanly criticize putin's
invasion and trump doesn't do it now
there was another really wacky moment in
this interview which is not getting as
much attention listen to what donald
trump had to say
about uh bald eagles
as he says
being killed by windmills trump is very
much against wind farms he says the
noise causes cancer not true
and listen to what he had to say
windmills because they're killing eagles
they're killing the bald eagle and other
eagles and other birds and we have these
windmills all over the place and the
environmentalists pretend they love them
but they're really hurting our country
they're driving down values they're just
absolutely killing it's one of the most
expensive forms of energy the turbines
are all made in china or germany so they
get the advantage of that
uh it's just ridiculous but the real
problem yeah
um do so so this has been studied and
this trump has been repeating this for
years and many on the right have been
repeating this about wind farms
do windmills kill some birds yes they do
they do
windmills kill
from
about 230 000 to 330
000 birds per year wow okay well that
that's significant right well maybe
cell and radio towers
cause nearly seven million bird deaths
per year well wait a sec wait a second
the wind farms kill 250 000 call it and
the cell and radio towers kill seven
million yes and they never talk about
that
cats okay i know a lot of cat owners
don't like this
cats kill
1.4 to 3.7
billion birds a year
billion with a b
okay so windmills are having no
statistically significant effect on the
bird population but you know what maybe
i'm being unfair because i'm comparing
bird deaths
from an energy generation mechanism to
other types of bird deaths okay well
if you consider
the oil and gas fields oil and gas
fields kill
500 000 to a million birds per year
already and you never hear about it okay
so this is a completely hypocritical
talking point everything we do has an
effect do you wear cotton
cotton requires a lot of water the water
that goes to make cotton clothing leads
to frogs and salamanders
dying because they have no uh
environment anymore the water is gone
okay i mean so then we'll maybe switch
to synthetic clothing oh but that's that
those are oil derivatives in many cases
and then you've got the birds
these things are complicated but one
thing we know for sure is that the bird
death toll from windmills is
statistically insignificant compared to
all the other things that we have in
industry that are killing birds now in
terms of eagles there's really no
specific data on how many bald eagles
are being killed by wind turbines the
estimate is that in total
about a hundred eagles a year die from
wind turbines in theory some of the
hundred are bald eagles i don't know it
depends you'd have to look more we don't
have that data but way more eagles die
from other things humans do
if you care about the eagles do you know
how many eagles die from hitting cars
do you know how many eagles die from
eating leftover lead uh i don't know if
it's called buckshot or just shot you
know ordinance of sort ammunition spend
it used eagles eat it and then they die
or eagles hitting electrified power
lines well shouldn't we be bearing power
lines oh no that's too expensive we
can't do that so this is nonsense it's
nonsense but as as is often the case
there's like a tiny somewhere there's
like a tiny little kernel of something
true about it and then they fixate on it
and then they blow it up and then they
repeat it uncritically so a very strange
interview there with sean hannity one of
our sponsors is curiosity stream the
only subscription streaming service that
specializes in documentaries my audience
can get a curiosity stream subscription
for only about a dollar a month at
curiositystream.com
pacman we all know netflix then hulu
they have some documentaries but
curiosity stream has a way better
selection in every category i'm always
finding documentaries on curiosity
stream i can't find anywhere else i just
watched electing lincoln which is a
three-part series about what led to the
election of abraham lincoln fascinating
absolutely fascinating curiosity stream
has an app for all of your devices i've
always got it going on the tv or i can
do put it on my tablet when i travel
with curiositystream i can explore a new
topic i never knew i'd be interested in
or
zone out with a great nature documentary
whatever you're looking for it's there
and you can get curiosity stream for
just 14.99 a year that's less than two
bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com pacman and use the
code pacman the link is down below